[Music]
one of the biggest problems i ran into
this is really embarrassing to say on
camera was
it's officially official four weeks of
going vegan are in the books and i'm so
happy i met my goal i have to thank you
guys for challenging me on my 30 days of
keto video
[Music]
just to clarify there are many reasons
why people follow a vegan diet moral
ethical environmental but the
information i'm going to cover here is
only what's related to nutrition and
health if you want me to talk about
those other concepts i'm happy to do so
drop me a line below and we'll make a
dedicated vegan video to just that
[Music]
a vegan diet can be a very healthy diet
whether you're young old somewhere in
between pregnant non-pregnant
breastfeeding not breastfeeding
basically it's applicable to all life
stages the reason i put that word can in
there you can follow a vegan diet eat
vegan burgers with sugary sodas with
gummy candies still be vegan and that's
not really healthy right and i have to
say it's not the only healthy diet out
there some of the loudest voices in the
vegan community are quick to say that
veganism is the only healthy option
that's not the case there are several
other healthy diets out there for
example the mediterranean diet that i'm
personally a fan of that are just as
healthy if not healthier than the vegan
diet
[Music]
i have to be honest and admit that i
don't generally recommend veganism as my
first option i do know that it's a
restrictive diet and we know restrictive
diets have high failure rates plus the
benefits of a vegan diet aren't that
much better than some of the other
alternatives that are simpler to follow
when i recommend a diet i'm trying to
create the healthiest diet but also one
that's feasible and achievable for my
patients to face without disrupting
their lives on the other hand if one of
my patients comes in and wants to follow
a vegan diet i'm totally in support of
that i just have to make sure that
they're adequately planning their meals
they're supplementing when need be
checking their blood tests and ideally
having some guidance either for myself
or a nutritionist
[Music]
the research behind health benefits of
following a vegan diet are substantial
and high quality if you're following the
standard american diet and then switch
over to a vegan diet you're going to see
improvement in chronic diseases like
diabetes heart disease strokes even an
extension of life in some cases and
what's most interesting is when we add
some animal products into the mix those
outcomes still hold true that's why what
i recommend to my patients is a
plant-focused diet meaning that they
should get the majority of their
calories from plants fruits vegetables
legumes nuts seeds healthy fats and a
moderate amount of poultry and fish with
a minimal amount of red meat in fact
that's the diet i follow and recommend
to my own family the field of nutrition
research is ever-changing and as we get
more information more quality studies we
doctors and nutritionists alike are
going to be able to give better
recommendations when it comes to a vegan
diet a plant-focused diet all of this is
susceptible to change but it's important
that we make the best decisions with the
knowledge that we have on hand the one
thing that i can say with a hundred
percent certainty is there's no such
thing as a miracle diet for everybody
[Music]
on day one i was excited i was like if i
could tackle keto i can definitely do
vegan first point at which i had a
little bit of hesitation was when i
ordered my first at-home delivery
[Music]
buffalo cauliflower bites
[Music]
with some kind of not real mayo
and this is a wrap
with vegan cheese
and unchicken
[Music]
i was having second thoughts and that's
not like me if i set a goal for myself
i'm gonna do everything in my power to
meet that goal but for some reason when
sticking to this vegan diet i was
concerned about so many things the
following week i was leaving to mit for
the leadership conference i was worried
if they're going to have vegan options
available for me i was then traveling to
miami for a few days all these worries
started bubbling in my head and i was
really wondering can i stick to vegan
this entire month why why should i do
vegans because it's more healthier for
you do you think so yeah but 30 days a
long time you just
do it
[Music]
one of the first obstacles i ran into on
the vegan diet was
under eating calories now i'm partially
to blame here because i didn't prep well
and even at the opening of this video i
said the healthy way to follow a vegan
diet is to adequately plan your meals
for the first two weeks i have to be
honest i didn't have much of an appetite
i'm not a huge fan of just eating
vegetables and rice and beans so i
didn't have tremendous portions and
because of that i was calorie deficient
i actually noticed some weight loss what
helped me tremendously to make up this
calorie deficit is eating some of these
snacks that thrive sent over if i didn't
have these snacks i'd be under eating
calories the majority of the time long
days in the hospital but i got my simple
meals these crackers
get me through some rough rough days
[Music]
one of the biggest problems i ran into
this is really embarrassing to say on
camera the whole plane ride i'm sitting
next to a doctor my stomach is going
to stand up like three four times from
day one up until
the last day of the diet i was having
tremendous gas and bloating it's so
embarrassing to say i mean think about
this i fly on planes i interact with
patients for long periods of time i sit
in conferences i can't just be sitting
there
flatulent i did try and isolate some
ingredients to see which ones were
causing this gas and bloating
combination for me but i couldn't find
out what it was i normally eat brown
rice i normally eat vegetables and
fruits and beans i expect them to go
away after four weeks but no they stuck
around i would have to say that the
vegan diet probably won't work for me
long term i just can't sit there with my
stomach going
and me wanting to
pass gas the entire time god that's
embarrassing
[Music]
what i didn't know about veganism is
that there are a ton of up-and-coming
options for those who aren't used to
eating vegan there are specialty
restaurants that just offer vegan foods
with no animal products that remind you
of foods that you may have eaten when
you ate animal products and i thought
that was really cool on top of that a
lot of these restaurants and even some
of the products i got from thrive
tasted delicious because of the sauces
vegan sauces are on point i'm loving
these blue chips but without some like
sauce like i'm really digging this
primal kitchen classic barbecue sauce
these chips just aren't cutting it
[Music]
i've talked about on this channel
of decision fatigue because you're
constantly making decisions and you're
using your willpower it's actually a
finite resource what i noticed while i
was following the vegan diet was that i
lost the the drive to go to the gym my
work ethic actually suffered because i
was putting such a strong
emphasis on sticking to vegan when there
were so many temptations and there were
things i wanted to eat i didn't want to
hop on my spin bike in my bedroom i
didn't want to go to the gym with my
friends this is really unlike me and
it's an obstacle i didn't actually
expect to face when i went to the gym i
lifted fine getting to the gym was the
actual struggle
[Music]
at the time i least expected it
disaster struck i got sick
i started coughing i got a sore throat i
got a low grade fever i went to see the
doctor i weighed the pros and cons of
starting antibiotics of stopping the
vegan diet i decided to stick with
conservative treatment and treat it like
a viral illness one of my favorite hacks
to treat viral illnesses actually the
symptoms of the viral illnesses is green
tea with
[Music]
patrol members manuka honey
free speaking police vegan please
apparently honey is not vegan
what i guess honey is an animal product
but man i didn't force the bees to make
the honey they make it on their own we
didn't have to milk them for it
wait if you want to disqualify my four
week vegan challenge because i ate honey
so be it
i gotta say at this point i was rolling
i was starting getting into the vegan
vibe i was trying out new restaurants i
was sampling all the delicious foods
that i got from thrive and i was excited
i was getting close to the finish line
but i will say one of the hardest things
with the vegan diet is peer pressure i
mean when i went out to eat with my
friends they were annoyed to say the
least that we had to choose the
restaurant based on my eating
preferences i did do a decent job at
trying to pick out vegan options in not
so vegan places look at this dedication
greek salad no feta
asparagus fries while i got this next to
me
while he is
[Music]
the vegan struggle is real
[Music]
honestly i was really proud of myself
and it's nice every now and then to take
a challenge like this and learn
something new about yourself in fact i
want to tell you five things that i
learned not only about the vegan diet
but also about myself during this
process one when i didn't plan well i
ate very unhealthy when i was at mit for
breakfast i ate cinnamon toast crunch
with almond milk and a banana every
morning that's not healthy even though
it's vegan two i didn't notice a major
change in my energy level like i thought
i would i mean maybe i had a slightly
decreased energy level but we have to
remember that i was sick in the
beginning i was under eating calories so
i don't feel it's fair to blame vegan
for that three surprisingly i didn't get
weaker on vegan i was lifting strong and
i felt good but what did suffer was
getting to the gym i really noticed a
lack of willpower when i was following
this restrictive diet four when it comes
to my body i lost three pounds i dropped
from 203 to 200 pounds so there was some
weight loss probably from under eating
calories but despite losing weight i
didn't feel as lean i mean all those
sauces all the rice that i ate pasta
that contributed to the carb load and
probably made me feel a little bit
pudgier than usual five this is the big
one the real difficulty was my gi system
i mean it was a mess the amount of gas
and flatulence and bloating god i can't
it's like gross even talking about but
it was really bad if you have that with
any diet there's no way you're sticking
with it and i tried taking some
over-the-counter supplements for this it
did absolutely nothing
[Music]
if you're curious or interested in
starting a vegan diet i don't want to
dissuade you in fact i want to encourage
you go talk to a dietitian nutritionist
physician someone who's well versed with
vegan diets that way you can do it the
healthy happy safe way without hurting
yourself in the process and please
reduce the amount of refined carbs and
processed foods that you're eating
because as more research comes out
that's the stuff that causes diseases
and shortens your lifespan now if you
want to check out a really cool playlist
check out my nutrition playlist right
here for some goodies
click here and stay happy and healthy
[Music]